centralizing control the Hong Kong
government is slashing public
involvement in local elections fewer
than 20 percent of district councilors
will be chosen by a public Democratic
vote the rest directly appointed by the
government or voted in by
state-controlled committees all
candidates will be vetted to assess
their patriotism
Hong Kong's political leader says this
will create a more stable future after
months of anti-government protests in
is the black violence it is the attempt
to make Hong Kong Independence and the
attempt to cause
disaster to Hong Kong society as a whole
that we need to put we need to prevent
I think that has to be made very clearly
we'll live through that and don't forget
it we have to bear that in mind so as to
ensure that in the long run the system
will protect us from all this
chaotic and harmful situation to arise
again
district council elections during those
protests saw a record voter turnout and
Landslide victories for pro-democracy
candidates critics of the new election
rules say they're designed to
marginalize public participation next
time around
it is about control and it indicates
that the government doesn't trust the
people of Hong Kong
they don't trust the people of Hong Kong
to do the right thing they don't give
them an opportunity to voice out their
views yet these District councilors
councils are supposed to be allowing the
government to gauge public opinion there
are reasons to be happy everywhere you
go in Hong Kong the changes come as
authorities are aggressively promoting
Hong Kong as a tourism and investment
hub
the government is spending millions of
dollars on campaigns from free flights
for visitors to discounted movie tickets
for residents all in a bid to improve
the public mood and help the economy
recover from lengthy covid-19
restrictions
the campaigns are attracting a lot of
attention but so too are the amendments
to the election laws that's prompting
concern it'll be Hong Kong's politics
rather than publicity campaigns that
seal its International standing Richard
Kimber Al Jazeera Hong Kong